hey this is raimu this talk is going to
be about
some of the things that i learned
as a long time cease plus plus developer
when i decided to learn rust
what are the things that i recognized
from c plus
what things were different what kind of
stood out to me as important to learn
and then what were the some of the
common mistakes that i made
my perspective
as learning rust which was only about a
month and a half ago
at first looked pretty similar to what i
already knew i could read and understand
the examples in the first few chapters
of the rust book
but looks can be deceiving right
lifetimes and borrow checking
to me
were very new
but also kind of welcome additions in in
a certain sense because
i thought
that the strictness of the language was
very appealing
that if we can catch more mistakes at
compile time
we won't have to find them at runtime
how strange and strict they can be
though
ran into a lot of compiler errors
didn't understand how to deal with them
until i got more and more used to it so
after some culture shock
i had the realization that strict can be
good
the language does guide you towards
better designs
many times once the compiler gives you
its blessing it just works right
so a few concepts in particular stood
out to me as important
and different from other languages
particularly c plus plus and i'd like to
talk about them today also a few types
of problems that i ran into seem to
occur more frequently than others
so
my initial approach to rust was let me
form associations between what i already
knew in c plus bus and what's in rust so
i found these plentiful readily
available so for example
void and z plus plus is the empty unit
in rust
all right so what i learned
which was different from c plus plus
that i tried to focus on some important
things
were to embrace
the
patterns involved with enumerations and
with match and if let and those kinds of
constructs so in this example we are
looking at the return value of a
function called lookup and this was a
little bit strange at first the syntax
that
you kind of have to read it not from
left to right but kind of from right to
left where you're calling this function
look up with an argument and you get
back something that has to match a
certain pattern in this case it has to
be a sum value for an optioning them and
then if it is
let's take a look at what's inside of
that sum which is that record
and the match in rust very similar to
the c plus plus switch right
instead of cases we have these arms
where we have more flexible and powerful
matching light syntax
but otherwise pretty similar
this though comes up a lot in rust where
you have to deal with
the enumerations and then the structure
of matches and if let's and it took me a
bit of time to get used to that i still
feel like i don't quite know how to
write it the most idiomatic way but it's
definitely a little bit different
so the second thing that i noticed in
rust which was
not so common in c plus plus at least
the code that i've seen
is the
usage of method chaining and combinators
especially when it comes to the types
option result iterator source and sync
they all seem to have these families of
functions you can call which you can
chain together
and can also manipulate input to to
output in in these chains so that you
can do quite a lot in one statement just
by chaining one function call to the
next
so the third thing that i really needed
to get used to this is
more recent addition to rust but very
welcome that is there is the concept of
futures and streams in asynchronous
programming in general
so
it's quite a bit different in c plus
plus so in rust i had to get familiar
with the concept that when you mark
something as async that it is going to
return a feature and then you have the
syntax where you can
wait on a feature if you're running in
the context of an executor
and along with features you have the
concepts of sources and sinks which are
kind of like the chaining of processing
but in this case it's with futures
and
this i'm still trying to get used to but
it is very powerful way to describe a
lot of asynchronicity in your program
and not something that you would see in
typically in c plus plus
so that said let's get into some traps
so these are
problems that i ran into trying to write
my own code where i kind of scratched my
head banging my head against the wall a
few times and
after i ran the same kinds of mistakes
multiple times i kind of got used to
what was what's the common
misconception that i had so number one
unintentional moves
so
this comes from i believe the fact that
in c plus
you usually don't move data you're
usually either passing references
or
you are
passing copies
whereas in rust the default semantics is
move so i tended to write code like this
where i said let me take the self.state
and let me match it against
this
variant see if it's an open state
and then i run to this problem it can't
move out of south state and i'd be like
what the heck i'm not trying to move
anything and then i had to remember that
yes you need to borrow that state and
its contents
otherwise you're going to be plucking it
out and you can't do that when the state
is the member of a larger object
so similarly
if we're actually
going to be looking at something in
order to modify it
i have you have to borrow it mutably so
that you can change its contents
and this
misconception i had
learning rust comes from the fact that
in c plus there really is no difference
in the caller's point of view
whether you're borrowing immutably or
not you don't have to add that mut
syntax token
all right second trap that i found
myself running into a lot this might be
familiar to some of you it is the
multi-borrow problem where
you
are running afoul of the borrower
checker because you have the same object
with many pieces and you're trying to
use many pieces at the same time
particularly if you're going to be using
a structure which has a function
implementation and then you try to pass
some of itself to that function
so we get this error message that i come
to realize as a sign that i am doing a
multi-borrow
so one solution of course
is to not borrow for the duration of the
function call but borrow it just long
enough to get a copy or clone so
we're still doing the same number
allocations but we moved it into the
collar
instead of the kali
and kind of separated the two boroughs
out
all right the third kind of trap and
this is the the most hairy kind of trap
that i
continue to run into is borrow's
escaping closures
so
in c plus they call closures lambda
expressions or anonymous functions and
they're a lot more loose so you can
go right ahead and hold a reference
forever when you shouldn't
and the compiler doesn't care and rust
it cares a lot so here's an example
where we have a closure that is going to
be mutating a variable which is a string
and this is fine right this doesn't have
any compiler errors because
we are going to be
using the closure and then not needing
it again
at the point at the last line there
where we're going to be printing out the
name the moment that you introduce
another use for that
name another borrow you get into this
problem where you have the variable
borrowed inside the closure and outside
it gets even worse if you decide to make
that closure asynchronous because not
only now
are you
capturing that a reference to name you
are holding on to it much longer to the
papyrus point of view because this
closure actually returns a future which
is itself something that doesn't
complete until possibly later
so one way i've learned how to solve
this and work around it is to use the
ref cell or the cell types which employ
interior immutability in this case our
closure doesn't need to hold on to a
mutable reference to something it can
use an immutable reference and share it
and it's a lot more flexible
and at the point where we need to mutate
it
we at run time do the borrow checking
and all's well
so key takeaways that i hope you get
from this talk
is that
if you're coming from a perspective of c
plus plus developer learning rust try to
leverage your existing knowledge many
concepts and syntax are the same or
similar
but embrace the common rust patterns
that are different than what you might
have gotten used to in c plus bus for
example match if let in patterns very
flexible and powerful tools
method chaining in combinators
used a lot more frequently in my
experience in rust
and then the
syntax that comes with asynchronous code
futures and streams come into play
more and more in modern rust
at the same time you need to learn how
to spot traps that are particular to the
differences between c plus bus and rust
for example unintentional moves multi
borrows and borrows escaping closures
the key thing to in my experience is to
recognize when the compiler is trying to
tell you about a certain category of
error and see that oh once again i'm
letting a borrow escape a closure that's
what that error message means anyway
that's from my experience learning rust
as a c plus developer thank you for
watching